going back to what you said about
representation let's say there's someone
landing here for the first time it's
there six years you know going back
would you suggest a spend time looking
for an agent or keep putting themselves
out there trying to get work on their
own and then hoping to get an Asian the
meantime yeah you know it's tough like
when I moved out here you know at least
from college that you know I which I was
in a big theater program um sorry um and
you know yeah of course they're like
okay fine agent or whatever you need to
get sagging you do all these things and
then I moved out here and I was working
with an acting coach and four you know
with this class for like three years and
he was very big on like just do the work
do the work and it will find you and I
believe that like I was like you know
what yeah like I'm just gonna continue
to do my own thing I you know if I can
fill my resume with tons of credits and
then can go into an agent's door get an
agent attention and say hey look I keep
myself busy like if I had your help
imagine what we can do yeah you know I
mean I felt like that would really work
and that's what I did you know like most
of my credits on my my resume most of
them if not yeah most of them were all
on my own hustle like even my television
credits like they came because I did a
TV show case through ABC you know I was
one of six actors one of six males
across the the city that was you know
handpicked by ABC and I did that and
that opened up so many doors for me but
it was like me hustling that opportunity
you know what I mean that guy ended up
getting the chance to get into these new
doors you know of course I had an agent
at that time and they get the
appointments and stuff but like if I
didn't look for that ABC opportunity and
go after an audition and put in the time
and book that you know I mean I wouldn't
have had those auditions coming in so um
I've done a lot of my own self just on
my own hustle and it's out there you
know like with the internet you know the
way it is and all the websites available
and just being able to reach out to
people and get contact information from
stuff you can we can do so much you know
that 30 40 years ago they didn't have
access to you know what I mean like they
couldn't do that unless they bumped into
somebody and they said all your
dominant you know but it's so different
now you know we can see a movie and in
10 minutes you can probably find
somebody you know that directed it on
Facebook or Twitter or whatever and try
to reach out so um I think like you know
big being being focused on an agent is
huge and you need to but I don't think
that that's the only thing you need to
do so if somebody moves here now
absolutely i mean i don't think anybody
can say you don't need an agent because
you do need an agent and your do need to
be Union I mean that those are two huge
things you need in town you know and i
and i was told that and i realize that
but i still think you know there's tons
that you can do without representation
and and honestly you know and I told
this to you know a couple of friends
recently you know who are dealing not
necessarily actors who have managers now
and I'm like just because you haven't
managed doesn't mean your job is done
man like you know unfortunately you know
again they work for you you were the CEO
of your company you know I am the CEO of
ace entertainment or whatever you know
what I mean it's like my agent my
manager you know whoever it is like
they're all I all I employ them you know
what I mean and and and and like you
have to think a bit about it like a
business sense and it's just like that's
why it's like well if your agents not
working for you you know if your car you
take your car into your mechanic for 40
you know that you've had for 10 years
and they're not doing the job like
what's gonna happen like you take your
car somewhere else to who will do it
same as a not gate an agent or manager
what how that works you know and I think
like when you have those people in place
that's more responsibility for for you
as the person looking over them you know
you can't just step back and say when
you think Bill Gates or you know when
Steve Jobs alive said well you know I've
got millions of employees now have fun
guys do it you know like no those are
some of the Harding hardest working
people you saw and you're like man they
have to continue to work hard to
maintain now that new level so I feel
like you know just you know a lot of
actors will get agents and they're just
like okay I'm done you know chillin now
like I don't have to do anything is like
no you have to work harder now because
guess what there's a reason why they get
ten percent or fifteen percent because
you are still responsible for doing
ninety percent or eighty five percent of
the work you know what I mean like it
doesn't mean that you can just sit back
and so you know you can
get work without agents and
representation and I still think when
you get it you still have to continue to
do it and work even harder because the
tendency is that you can relax you know
what i mean but no you have to keep
track and make sure that everybody's in
line you know because I mean believe me
I it happens to me all the time where
I'll catch things I'm like well I didn't
go in on that and then I'll reach out
and and it was missed you know it's just
like and maybe we can find it in time to
go in and then it's happened where I can
get the appointment you know what i mean
so you know we're all human beings and
people are tied up I'm not the only
person all my teams represent you know
so they're spreading their time
throughout other people and it's just an
age of the game you know where
something's gotta give and sometimes
they do you know so I would absolutely
say look for an agent you know don't
feel that you have to have one and the
wheel or the world's done but at the
same time like keep busy do do you know
theatre do you know do good work find
good people to work and you know you
know like I can look back at all the
stuff that I've done and and you know
some of them were work great and some of
them were awful experiences but they
were learning experiences for me and you
have you get just as much from those as
the good ones you know and that's it i
think it's like you know learning taking
in all those experiences but knowing and
trusting your gut because all those
experiences were the things weren't as
smooth or they didn't go as well at some
point in the very beginning I had that
feeling that's like I don't know you
know but I didn't trust my gut I was
like man but i guess i need this
experience or i need footage for my reel
or i need all these things so i thought
i had to do it and that the day all that
ended up being was a lesson you know
what I mean so um absolutely I tell it
to all my friends like I'm really active
with like my old college and they have a
great thing of putting the current
students in touch with alums and you
know myself and a couple of others or
the first people they kind of put us in
touch to put them in touch with because
we're all you're doing it and that's
always what I say is like guys you you
know create your own work especially now
like that's even even from a producing
standpoint the feedback that we've
received from one film to the next in
one year from selling one filming now
trying to sell our film is that it's
moving so fast in terms of people you
know like the
just are embracing the fact that you
know you can do it so much on your own
like as a filmmaker and as an actor you
know so you know we have we have the the
the reason why it's changing is because
it's so oversaturated now because
everybody can have a good camera that
can look good now and you look on
youtube and that's like a channel for
producers and little in upcoming
directors everybody has a mac that they
can edit their video and put sound and
all these things know they're creating
their content at like three years old
you know I mean so and you know
naturally the market is now set
oversaturating so much more because now
there's so much more content people are
able to deliver so I think you know um
do your own work you know I mean take
that you know take technology take what
we have it you know at our disposal now
and like really you know there's no
reason why you can't have a you know
footage of yourself or a short or
something that you've worked on because
every iPhone every every every phone now
has I mean I think now technology just
gives us the ability to have uh you know
work for ourselves to create work for
ourselves so I think like you know go
out there produce direct you know or
just find people that that have those
skills that's another thing everybody's
out there that that you know where this
town is full of people that have
different talents and stuff and it's
just about finding that the right people
i mean that's that's what was at the
heart of what we eventually did but by
making our movies it was like i was a
tired of not you know having stuff going
when I knew all these people that could
do you know different things so you know
I don't think there's a reason to be
held back by not having an agent or any
of that when you move here
you